Transcriptor: Charlie Hernandez
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Llevo 22 años en el área
de la docencia y debo decir
que es de las experiencias
más bellas que he vivido.
Soy de esas maestras que se levanta
todos los días contenta de ir a trabajar.
Como dicen por ahí:
cuando uno trabaja en lo que te gusta,
definitivamente, no es trabajo.
Sé que muchas veces, como adultos,
nos hemos quedado en blanco
frente a alguna pregunta
hecha por los pequeños de la casa.
Y pasan segundos,
que para nosotros son minutos,
antes de dar con esa respuesta
que creemos correcta.
Y cuando la decimos, ¿qué sucede?
Pues que viene una pregunta aún peor
que la anterior, ¿y qué podemos hacer?
Nos quedamos otra vez en blanco
y dejamos ahí el tema.
Pero ¿a qué se debe que los adultos
no podamos dar respuesta a esas preguntas
cotidianas de nuestros niños?
Simplemente es por una falta de recursos.
Y la pregunta es:
¿dónde puedo conseguir esos recursos?
La respuesta es más sencilla
de lo que parece.
En los cuentos infantiles.
Yo creo que los cuentos infantiles
son realmente mágicos.
Cuando leemos una historia a un niño,
observamos inmediatamente
cómo hace conexión con el personaje,
cómo su postura corporal empieza a cambiar
y cómo logra relacionar esa historia o esa
trama con alguna historia de su vida real,
consigo mismo.
Yo defino ese proceso como mágico.
Cuando empecé a entender
el fenómeno de los cuentos infantiles,
debo decir que me convertí
en una consumidora activa de ellos.
No hay un día que no entre en una librería
y no vaya directa al área de los cuentos
para los pequeños de la casa.
Y trate de buscar alguna historia
que tenga sentido, significado
y que me permita
un espacio para la reflexión.
Pero ese ritual tenía que compartirlo
con mi otra pasión, el aula escolar.
Así que todos los días en mi clase
intento buscar ese espacio para leer
una pequeña historia que me permita
hacer reflexionar a mis niños
o me permita encontrar
la solución a un conflicto
que estén viviendo en ese momento.
Debo decirles que mi profesión
me permitió adentrarme de lleno
en el mundo de la escritura.
¿Por qué? Porque tenía en mis manos
un montón de historias.
Cada uno de mis alumnos era un cuento,
una historia que tenía en ese momento
y que valía la pena contar.
Así que solamente tenía
que tomar una hoja de papel,
escribir lo que estaba observando
y darle un final positivo.
Al día siguiente me dirigía al aula
y lo contaba en alguna reunión.
Y la respuesta era maravillosa.
Los niños conectaban
perfectamente con la historia,
ya fuera porque alguno de ellos
era el protagonista o porque lo conocían.
Debo decirles, que actualmente he tenido
la oportunidad de encontrarme
con muchos de mis alumnos,
que por supuesto hoy ya son adultos,
ya que llevo 22 años en esta área.
Y lo que recuerdan con más cariño,
son esos momentos
en la jornada de lectura.
Inclusive logran recordar alguna voz
especial que ponía a algún personaje
o cómo repetidamente,
siempre contaba la misma historia,
para ver si lográbamos
llegar a una conclusión.
Tras tantos años en esa área,
pude observar que Venezuela se convirtió
en un país de despedidas.
Empecé a vivir muy de cerca
el tema del exilio.
Se empezaron a ir mis amigos,
mis familiares y sobre todo mis alumnos.
Comencé a tener mucha tristeza.
Estaba muy cercana a ese sentimiento
de tristeza y de desolación
que me dejaba el vacío
de las personas que amaba.
Pero sumado a esa tristeza,
empecé a ver un fenómeno.
Y era que recibía constantemente
llamadas de los alumnos de mi clase.
Querían saber cómo estaba.
Querían saber cómo estaban
sus compañeros de clases.
Querían ver su aula.
Incluso recibía llamadas de sus madres,
diciéndome que habían notado
algún tipo de cambio en su conducta.
O mis amigas me llamaban para decirme
que sus hijos extrañaban a sus abuelos,
a sus amigos y su vida.
Así que comencé a escribir de nuevo.
Pero esta vez empecé a escribir
a través de mi historia.
Lo que estaba pasando
en ese momento era real.
Y así nace “Camila.
Por fin me sentí en casa”.
Camila, es la historia de una niña
que debe enfrentar el exilio familiar,
debe intentar entender todo lo desconocido
y empezar a descubrir
un mundo que no había vivido antes.
Casa nueva, colegio nuevo, comida nueva.
En esta historia que estaba escribiendo,
Camila también era un personaje real,
y era un personaje real para mí.
Era cada uno de mis alumnos
que había tenido que dejar su colegio
y cada uno de los hijos de mis amigas
que habían tenido que dejar su vida.
Así que, luego de escribir
una historia tan cercana a mí,
decidí compartirla de manera informal
con cada una de las personas
que yo tenía fuera del país
a través de un correo electrónico,
en un manuscrito sin mucha forma.
Y les pedí que por favor
me dieran su opinión
acerca de la historia que estaban leyendo.
Y la sorpresa fue gigante.
Los hijos de mis amigos conectaban
de manera inmediata con Camila.
Eran los mismos sentimientos
a los que ella se enfrentaba:
rabia, frustración, tristeza.
Pero lo más increíble era ver cómo los
adultos que lo leían me llamaban
y me decían:
“Andre, yo también soy Camila.
Yo también he tenido miedo
a este nuevo mundo”.
En ese momento, mi historia
solamente había sido leída por mis amigos.
Pero en algún momento dije:
“¿Qué voy a hacer con Camila?
¿Qué hacemos con ella?“.
Así que me pongo a trabajar
y decido hacer de Camila un cuento.
Pero era difícil pensar
que alguien que no me conociera
quisiera comprar o leer mi historia.
Entonces, un día decidí ponerme a trabajar
y hacer de Camila un sueño hecho realidad.
Pero no contaba con que la pandemia
iba a llegar en ese momento.
Camila se enfrentaba
a una pandemia mundial.
Y pese a todo lo difícil del proceso,
Camila logra salir en plena pandemia
y en una crisis mundial,
a través de las plataformas de Amazon
en formato impreso,
y en formato físico en Venezuela.
Pensé que la pandemia
iba a ser un obstáculo para ella,
pero fue todo lo contrario.
El fenómeno que vino
tras su publicación fue maravilloso.
Comencé a recibir un montón de llamadas
de todas partes del mundo:
España, Portugal, Alemania, Miami, Alaska,
que me decían
que la historia era maravillosa.
Incluso recuerdo muchos mensajes
internos y correos electrónicos.
Pero hubo un par de mensajes
que me llamaron mucho la atención,
y uno de ellos fue el de una madre,
que se tomó la molestia de mandarme
un correo electrónico para decirme
que gracias a la historia de Camila,
había comprendido a la perfección
el proceso por el que
estaba pasando su hija.
Habían podido buscar ayuda y ahora estaban
trabajando en su proceso de exilio
y se sentían muchísimo mejor.
También recuerdo un padre que me escribió,
y me dijo que su hija
no estaba pasando por ese proceso
porque había nacido en el país
donde ellos compraron el libro,
pero que tenía amiguitas en su colegio
que estaban pasando por lo mismo,
y quería regalarles un par de cuentos
a cada una de ellas,
porque ellas también eran Camila.
Pero ¿a qué se debía
el fenómeno de Camila?
¿Qué hacía de Camila
una historia totalmente diferente
a las historias que había escrito antes?.
Pues entendí perfectamente
que los personajes que narraba
a través de la realidad o de la ficción,
le permitían al niño ver el mundo
desde otra perspectiva
y poder comprender
el mundo que los rodeaba.
Entendí también que Camila
era una historia real
que le podía pasar a cualquiera, a ti,
a mí, a tu hijo, al compañero o al vecino.
También entendí el fenómeno
o la importancia que tienen
los cuentos infantiles en el crecimiento
de las emociones de nuestros niños.
No es lo mismo hablar de lo que le sucede
al personaje de un cuento
que hablar de lo que nos sucede
a nosotros mismos.
Todos estamos expuestos diariamente
a muchas situaciones, con los vecinos,
los amigos y los familiares,
que les afectan a ellos y a nosotros
Por eso los invito a que observen
a cada una de esas personas,
a esa historia maravillosa que contar, que
podemos poner en papel y sacarla a la luz
Los invito a ser creadores
de su propia historia,
de esa historia maravillosa
que todos tenemos que contar.
Como suelo decir: detrás de un gran cuento
solamente hay la voluntad de hacerlo
y las ganas de escribir.
Creo que el ser docente me permitió entrar
de lleno a este mundo de la escritura
y compartir de la mano
lo que es educar con valores
y a través de la escritura
y de la lectura.
Hace un tiempo hablé con un gran amigo,
un artista venezolano, que me dijo:
“Si al contar alguna de tus historias
ayudaste a alguien,
entonces valió la pena”.
Gracias.